[Music]
hey
uh new rockstars daily show that keeps
you updated on just what's happening
right now in nerd news we are 100 live
though we are also 100 remote uh for the
last day the plan is tomorrow we'll be
back in our office in our actual break
room uh but for day we're excited to be
here with you we're talking doctor
strange top gun dune star wars and of
course
we've got some gorse to discourse okay
uh we're gonna be talking thor love and
thunder uh with me to discuss
we've got uh dishonorably discharged
from multiple arby's mr brandon barrack
oh yes they won't let me near the meats
anymore
we've got um uh
always a maiden never undermated voyage
we've got jessica clemens
i know that's right
i know that's right and and finally the
rear admiral of the poop deck mr tommy
back though hey what's up everybody we
want to give a special shout out to the
tom squad always defusing conflicts all
right love every one of you love every
one of my fans so thankful for you so
grateful for you on this wednesday this
glorious wednesday
oh i love it what a nice way to start us
off there tommy uh real quick
we'll be watching that chat we'll have
some polls going on throughout the show
and we appreciate you folks that are
throwing in a couple bucks in the super
chat when we hit
multiples of 100 bucks in the super chat
it will unlock
our swear jar now our swear jar allows
one of us to swear we're not supposed to
be cursing or using profanity otherwise
we could only do it the scc well only
the fcc the scc the naacp none of them
will allow us to curse on this show only
when um we hit 100 bucks on the swear
jar and today for the first time we're
going to run a quick poll when we hit
that to determine who gets to swear
sorry yeah are we not going to
acknowledge that jessica just curled her
lashes live on the air
shut up shut up this show this show it's
real that's how you know your personal
vanity jesse that's just right you sound
like every teacher i had in high school
[Music]
they were right wow they were like
jessica please we're having a fire drill
stop curling your lashes i said after
i'm finished i mean how are we supposed
to proceed with straight lashes in this
show we we uh yeah we need her to be
able to see everything
you know for our haters who think the
show's not live i just want to celebrate
once again the tigers winning 4-2 and
extra innings just moments ago okay okay
everybody the show's freaking live very
live or or we recorded 17 versions of
this show with every possible score
outcome yeah
over a million i've looked at over a
billion different outcomes and only one
ends with the tigers winning 42.
only one uh okay let us begin the show
with the headlines
great all the news uh you want to know
about that's coming out today uh the
twitter account doctor strange updates
posted an unfinished deleted scene of uh
from multiverse of madness of wang
rintra i think i'm pronouncing that
right that's our green uh bull looking
uh wizard there and uh some other camera
taj sorcerers climbing up wonder gore
mountain to learn more about the dark
hold it's just a quick shot no dialogue
or anything like that you see a couple
sorcerers flying off the mountain after
some kind of wind blast or something
like that um any thoughts on this what
this could have mean because like
we never saw any sorcerers beyond wong
and strange
right uh at wonder gore
yeah i mean i i to me it seems like this
was maybe an original you know like this
was maybe the original play before they
went to the reshoots where they would be
rather than being
brought there by wanda whether long
being brought there as a hostage by
wanda they were perhaps pursuing her you
know for or or or trying to intervene
and get there before
like maybe maybe it's maybe she finds
out about the second darkhold
uh from another from another comrade
sorcerer and then it's a race to
wondercore mountain
and in this case them flying back
represents the fact that
good old wanda maximoff got there first
can't be beat i was thinking maybe they
were coming to rescue wong or something
like oh they're like we should probably
go get him he saved a lot of us by
getting her out of here
took a lot of the torture for us so uh
we should go get him
all of them would be destroyed by the
rock people yeah
maybe the rock people who did nothing
ever yeah maybe that did nothing ever
that disappeared they died in a
spectacular fashion i guess um oh in
other news echo writer marianne dayer i
think i'm hoping i'm pronouncing that
name right uh shared a new logo on
twitter for the echo series that has
started filming um you know a nice font
marvel's always especially in their like
disney plus days or their comic con
presentations they're always giving you
some real fun fonts for all the
different shows and the productions and
they're so limited because avatar has
the the dominance on papyrus so they're
not able to use it
they changed it tommy i won't allow this
this what does it have a comic sans one
of the all-time best snl sketches just
look up papyrus snl
uh ryan gosling at his best it delayed
it delayed avatar two six years because
they were working on those spots okay
yeah you're right it's now it's a crisp
uh cambria or something like that yeah
yeah it's a sans serif times old roman
is what i always think about um and and
we'll be getting little drips and drives
of the echo series i think that's coming
out next year is somewhere on the docket
you know uh marvel and disney plus love
to kind of shuffle those things around
but it's filming now which is a great
sign uh speaking of filming now sony has
released the first plot details for its
upcoming madame webb uh film starring
dakota johnson and uh sydney sweeney of
um
uh euphoria and white lotus fame uh and
and they dropped you know it was
otherwise just kind of a normal uh
notice but they dropped a sentence in it
was kind of the first confirmation of
plot details and the sentence was the
film will be an origin story of the
clairvoyant madame webb whose psychic
abilities allow her to see within the
spider world now that's very similar to
the comic book uh backstory of the
character but like
do we think see within the spider world
are we going to see a tom holland are we
going to see a tom hardy what kind of
spider world are we going to be peeking
into i hope it pulls i hope that for
whatever reason out of nowhere the
madame web movie is the one that brings
like holland
topher grace
hardy
like uh joe mongalio or whatever the guy
who played flash thompson in the
original
one who's like hunky uh true blood
honestly i mean i hope it's like she's
just like
a cartoon miles morales maybe a real
life miles morales she pulls them all in
are they over are they over versing the
spider verse is this too much like have
we done the team ups now a couple i mean
you push your head into the spider verse
which was animated but it was
well lauded and you're gonna have a
sequel to that we've had no way home
it's like are we getting tired of like
this
nope nope i mean you're
i mean jessica has a good point i guess
in that like the comics have basically
embraced it they're like no they're
always gonna be together the only time
we ever really as a nation
experience spider-man fatigue was when
they made it like they took all the fun
out of it and just made it serious which
was kind of like the culmination of the
amazing spider-man 2 right it was like
here's a humorless take on spider-man
and that was not the fault of you know
andrew garfield by any means but it was
like what if we made all of like the the
whimsy and like you know or or at least
just like
you know
uh humor of spider-man being so young
and having so much responsibility and
great power as famously noted uh
like what if we took that all away and
just made it kind of like a brooding emo
like
tragedy
and then yeah and and you know and then
and then and it came back with great
success once they restored all that with
tom holland so yeah let's let's hope
jessica's right nobody's tired we can
always have more spider version and that
as long as they kind of come at it right
yeah we'll gobble it up we'll continue
to gobble it up
yeah
bryce dallas howard shot down some
rumors it was kind of a tick tock that
went viral that she has been either cast
as invisible woman or is set to be the
director of the upcoming fantastic four
movie kind of like a fan presented her
with a funko pop of
of uh sue storm invisible woman and she
was like no no no those rumors aren't
true which who knows maybe that is
a vacuum confirmation maybe it is truly
she's just shooting down rumors but her
name is kind of getting linked with that
property in multiple different ways
uh which is cool i say gender bend the
thing go switch them switch them
yes
yes
that's the body type we want the the
thing i mean we have no one they're not
getting chiklis back and they ain't
calling me
so it sounds like yeah it's yeah
alice i think
and they're not calling i think uh bryce
house howard will be in the um the
fantastic four movie but as reprising
her role as gwen stacy i think she's
gonna be here yeah older gwen stacy
working for the baxter foundation
take it to the bank bold oh my god
that's that's a barrack guarantee
if it doesn't come true you know hit me
up i'll refund you the cost of your
ticket to the movie
it's a barrack brick couple more of
those and you can build an outhouse um
we've got more marvel discussion coming
up but first uh we're gonna dip our toes
into some star wars stuff because this
is a big week for star wars tomorrow
tommy's hitting the road heading down to
anaheim for star wars celebration he's
going to be down there with eric voss
probably get some reports back probably
get some fun content for both the break
room and the new rockstars youtube
channel and social media channels and
we're getting two episodes of obi-wan
dropping late thursday early friday
we're hoping maybe we get an andor
trailer maybe we get some uh ahsoka
early footage who knows what we might
get but we're already starting to get
some drips and drabs of star wars news
coming out ahead of this like uh ewan
mcgregor and hayden christensen have
been doing a lot of press for obi-wan
and ewan mcgregor told entertainment
weekly that while while kenobi has
brought a version of obi-wan closer to
the alec guinness representation from
the original trilogy he's still open to
making more seasons uh and we need a
a name for this on the break room any
time an actor's like sure i'd make more
i'd make more episodes of this or sure
i'd be in more movies right like the um
the official like i'll take i'll take
more checks at the stanford it's like
that like yeah
thirsty
yes yes yeah i got to say guys we're so
excited eric and i have been texting
back and forth i've got my ag-1
individual packets ready to go uh from
athletic greens i'm going to be firing
those in my stomach every morning and
then i'm going to be ready to take on
kathleen kennedy and dave fallon i mean
with the hard-hitting questions we've
been wondering like what does thrawn's
butthole look like you know stuff like
that
just
will we see it all my questions are
gonna
be butthole related
[Music]
the woodward and bernstein of the uh
star wars universe the ronin hero of uh
star wars investigative journalism i'm
working phillip pretty hard to have a
video come out saturday that's like max
repo how does he go to the bathroom with
a with an arrow pointing in between
those massive legs he plays the key
oh god so stay tuned guys if that's not
a reason to get you watching the break
room thursday and friday i don't know
what it is because i'm sending in vlogs
and i'm sending in hogs which are just
hugs by me
chunky hugs oh
ah in an interview with uh joe.i.e
hayden christensen teased the upcoming
uh vader vs kenobi confrontation saying
it's a personal mission for him
we've in and now this kind of sparked us
we were talking about this earlier in
the office you know
the the vibe
coming out ahead of kenobi is that this
is like redemption for hayden
christensen and his performance in the
prequel trilogy right and and we just
had
in spider-man no way home kind of andrew
garfield getting kind of his redemption
in his portrayal of peter parker are
there other characters that we feel like
or or actors and their portrayal of a
character that we feel like are due
for a redemption that haven't yet had it
out there
get that ben affleck daredevil in here
baby let's see uh the multiverse open
and old man daredevil comes through
a little eating a little tired
absolutely i think that brandon i kind
of took your from our morning discussion
you had mentioned topher grace
returning as venom or maybe it was zack
i can't remember but it was uh it was
one of you two i get you confused you
both look the same all white people look
the same to me well part of the problem
is in that morning meeting we're both
dialing in from our bunk beds
i don't know how your wife's put up with
that but it is amazing this is part of
our contracts
it's part of the uh yeah sometimes you
guys do bubble baths where you're just
sitting at opposite ends of the tub and
you call in and that's those are my
favorite meetings uh jessica and i do
that too but for a different reason uh
anyway yeah i say toe for grace bring
him back
what a waiting what a way to get to that
um
in the uh star wars issue of variety uh
kathleen kennedy revealed that leslie
hedland
is uh pulling heavily from the star wars
extended universe or the legend stories
for the upcoming acolyte series um i
don't think that's one that has not
started filming yet that one's further
down on the pipeline than a lot of the
other series we're talking about so
we're not hoping to see any footage of
that anytime soon i think they're still
kind of in the writers room for that and
uh fans are hoping uh many aspects of
those legend stories to become canon
because as of now they have not been
treated that way right
yeah the fans are so like
really hardcore star wars fans love
those legends stories our own uh
producer dodson is a huge
legends fan and like the idea of some of
these stories
becoming canon again i think it's so
important for them because when disney
kind of you know cr like when they took
over
lucasfilms and then kind of placed all
of these stories in the eu they're like
this is the extended universe these
aren't necessarily canon anymore i mean
i know a lot of people kind of felt like
they lost time off of their like their
like fan lives like where they were like
wow i spent 10 years reading the
novelizations of dash rendar you're
telling me
this is not canon anymore i love me some
dash rendar baby yeah no who doesn't but
uh anyway yeah i think that
there's a lot of fans that are excited
by the idea of acolyte restoring some of
their favorite legends and it's cool too
it's getting
really far away from the skywalker yeah
too right like that's way hundreds of
years supposed to be about 100 years
before phantom menace i think something
like that and i think it's a great idea
i mean there's all tons of extended
universe what is now known as legends
canon i think they're doing a good job
of picking the cream of the crap to come
in it doesn't all need to come in some
of those stories are all over the place
but like you know we we know they're
bringing thrawn in they've already
dropped his name an official like star
wars universe so it's like and that's a
great character that's much beloved it
was obviously in the clone wars and
stuff like that rebels um but yeah i
think there's a lot of
datsun was mentioning revvin was like a
very popular character from this time
let's see on this show uh so i'm i am
really excited to see a whole host of
new characters maybe maybe we'll get
some more information maybe we'll get
some casting maybe we'll get some
some dates some release dates some
synopsises uh
tommy our reporter in the field will be
uh
coming through
twisted fingers and all oh yes
uh and then two last quick headlines
here that are non marvel or star wars
related uh i love this this popped up
yesterday but the duffer brothers the
creators of this stranger things series
said that you know they're they're
planning a the stranger the current
stranger things story will end after its
fifth season uh but then they're
planning already a spin-off that they
haven't told any about anybody about
including netflix though apparently just
on set one day actor finn wolfhard uh
correctly guessed the premise of it so
either it's extremely easy and any
random uh 16 year old can figure it out
or
you know maybe he's got a little
clairvoyance in it maybe he's got the
shining in him i think i don't know i
think he cheated and he hacked some
emails tommy i gotta let you know
there's some late-breaking news you've
won the poll to swear
our first swear has been unlocked tommy
and the people think you deserve it for
some reason wow that's
absolutely incredible now is this a
profanity-laden tirade or do i just get
one swear i mean you do what they're
saying
i gotta tell you i am so [ __ ] excited
to go to the god damn star wars
celebration tomorrow those [ __ ]
have no idea what this big bastard's
gonna bring to that scenario i'm talking
[ __ ] photo shoots i'm talking [ __ ]
meeting greets i'm talking bring your
best [ __ ] to me i'll sign it i'll sign
you you sign me people sign in my tits
i'm signing their kids it's gonna be
[ __ ] crazy i'll sign butts i'll sign
nuts i'll sign coconuts and you can take
that to the [ __ ] bank baby cause i'm
a man
that was a good tirade wow
wow whoever a couple folks that pushed
us
orton chop chopin just me everybody that
contributed to that i think we all got
our money's worth
took the call from youtube right now
this isn't that
shut down this video uh
it was the signing
but
and then finally i just my last headline
here i want to push my pro dune agenda
there we go definitely my favorite movie
last year i'm so jazzed for the the
sequel coming up austin butler who we'll
see soon portraying elvis presley
uh in in that that film uh has been
officially cast as fade rotha uh the uh
the nephew of uh baron harkin um the
brother to dave batista's beast rabon uh
this comes along with we're getting
florence puke as the um princess ireland
we're getting um christopher walken
as uh the emperor i mean cass is coming
together deniseville news out there
teasing a third film hasn't even started
filming on the second and he's teasing
the third that's that that
best be thirsty
for one baby i ain't doing two thirsty
thespians and drunk directors right
there everybody was driven directly i
said i'd keep one dude i'm not i won't
do another one
i'll play the emperor one time
that's it
that's a beautiful impression but we
gotta get to back to thor guys enough
with these headlines it's time for our
break breaker breakdown guys break rope
right now
uh
there's so much going on in this thor
love and thunder trailer if you saw on
the channel eric put out his breakdown
of the of the trailer yesterday 20
minutes for a little minute and a half
trailer beautiful work eric we love it
as always uh but there was a really
interesting theory he brings up uh in
his breakdown that could connect
you know the actions of gore with stuff
that was brought up in the eternals uh
john will you roll that clip for him
this blue skinned race is actually the
same tribe that the guardians fight
alongside in the other shots i'm
thinking they're the zatoan tribe of the
planet centauri war the same tribe as
yondu which is why the guardians feel
such a kinship with this tribe wanting
to defend yondu's home planet so this
planet is yondu's homeworld of centauri
4 that would make these other planets
and stars in the sky part of the alpha
centauri system alpha centauri being the
largest sun in the sky and it's
interesting that we can see so many of
the other planets in the horizon because
it could be how this movie visually
conveys my theory that centauri's
neighboring planet of centuries 6
referenced in eternals as a past planet
that the eternals helped destroy to
birth the celestial could get referenced
in this movie we might even see the
ruins of that planet in the sky and that
could be the home world of gore the
reason why he hates all gods now
i really love this theory
mainly because
in the comics you know gore is from a
planet that doesn't have a name
it's kind of part of his story where
it's just like it doesn't matter right
he's he's one of many people in the in
the universe who feels like they've been
betrayed by a godly figure who's
supposed to protect them and you know
within the marvel universe there's uh
strong evidence that gods are real you
know we can have that debate in our
universe all we want uh but god is a
woman uh and she's real uh but for gore
you know he's had enough right but i
love this idea that he's from this
planet that we've heard about
via you know the eternals when a theme
kind of has that memory of destroying
centauri six or the destruction of
centauri six
uh i love this idea that gore's from
there like that ties this all together
so well uh which i think would be really
interesting but wouldn't it mean he's
been around for a long time because that
would have happened thousands of years
ago uh according to like i think his
race is
aren't they very old i mean maybe that's
just me i think they are very old that's
why i was like that makes sense i but
keep going i didn't mean to interrupt oh
no no that's the fair question that also
could explain some of his appearance
right like maybe he didn't always look
that way but now that he's lived a
thousand years hunting down gods maybe
he's kind of well also in the comics he
was like stranded in the desert for days
and they probably days doesn't sound
like a lot to some people but so they
probably in the movie stretched the
truth and was like he was stranded in
the desert for months without water or
food and a day
you know to us is how long it takes our
planet to rotate once in a year is how
long it takes it to go around the sun
for every planet in our solar system
those figures are very different so a
day for someone could be thousands of
our years you know yeah so he could have
been wandering forever in the sun in the
sand crawling and he also is like
someone that is able to breathe in space
and like fly and do all this other stuff
you think their body's gonna
marvel has done a really bad job of
making us feel like people should look
like this no matter how much they can
lift drink do whatever the heck they're
doing but uh this man is real
oh oh my god
god bless um god bless god bless
the super chat we've hit another
milestone there so we'll run a poll and
determine who gets to unleash a filthy
filthy uh tirade jonathan pitcher
wow thank you for your generosity um i
like that thought
wouldn't it be wild though like we know
that floating head of nowhere has been
out there you know there's other gods
we're talking about that we've never
seen so maybe they've been killed off
screen like catholic right or or
different kind of celestial beings but
like
how low-key has this guy been not loki
but l-o-w k-e-y that like he's able to
behead a celestial and nobody's
whispered his name yet in an mcu film
right yeah
wild yeah i love that idea
well we don't know what the necro swords
powers have given this guy you know
maybe it gave him like the ability to
live for even longer than he's supposed
to live or be around for a long time but
that's a good point zach because like if
he's been
i i don't i hope this movie doesn't set
up that like oh yesterday he started
killing gods and here we go the idea
that he's been out there for a long time
that just hasn't popped up on our radar
yet or hasn't gotten even close to earth
because in the comics you know they
established that all these different
planets have their own gods and their
own deities i think of all the gods that
we have on earth uh all these planets
could have multiple iterations of god so
if he's just out there taking out gods
that are far away from anything we know
maybe he's never shown up on on like
thor's radar before and now he's being
drawn to us he's he's he's he's so he's
well who couldn't be drawn to you
brandon but first but
and also like we we've learned kind of
from like movies and literature like
longevity and immortality breeds
insanity right like the longer someone
is alive
in a book or a movie it's like they tend
to like even if they don't age at that
rate and they're not ancient looking
they tend to have just experienced and
seen
so much traumatic stuff that they're
insane and they feel justified in doing
these ultra violent acts and like
basically acts of genocide or acts of
mass murder because they're like well
i've basically seen other people doing
this for their various causes and
they're you know they're what they feel
is righteous and now it's my turn and i
have a feeling with gore it's going to
be that case where it's like yes he's
now reached an ancient point and he's
completely insane
we've all found in the last couple years
that the more isolated you are the more
nuts you go yeah uh and if you only have
an evil sword and maybe a bunch of goo
monster black goo monsters to kind of
like keep you company
that will maybe uh speed up the going
nuts process absolutely awesome now
jessica i have a question for you do you
think that gore might have killed any
gods in the mcu already
do you think that's possible and i want
you to consider this as you answer as
your answer you won our next swear you
were gifted the next swear
so as you answer feel free to throw some
some uh obscenities into your your
response here but yeah maybe not even a
guy that is driving me insane maybe not
even a cat a god that we've seen jessica
but like a god that hasn't shown up in
the mcu that's prominent in the comments
because gore has already killed them
oh that's a good question that's a good
[ __ ] question i am so i'm sorry to
like jump in this right [ __ ] now my
cat is driving me insane she thinks that
i took the [ __ ] juice the dumb [ __ ]
juice today and i did not and it's
pissing me off i
you guys out there were kids i know how
i know your life
maybe gore had a cat maybe gore had a
cat
gore got a cat and was like i need to go
kill every god right now
i would never ever harm my cat but it
this makes me want to fly into space and
kill all the gods um i don't i i feel
like he definitely has killed someone
already but the thing that i'm irritated
about is it's going to be such a
minuscule god to us because we haven't
seen them in mcu we're going to be like
oh we're not going to have any
attachment to what that god is so i
think he definitely has i'm trying to
think of one of the ones that he
well he's been he's he's been chasing
odin forever but odin's already dead
unless odin comes back what if it gets
revealed that like he killed bore at
some point like he was the one that
killed boar although he's been out there
he's been out there for a while like a
lot of times i think i think it was just
like with like odin and boar you know we
saw odin just kind of like i'm dead
and like dissipates and i think it's
assumed boar did essentially the same
thing but what if it was like an
involvement of gore at some point maybe
that'll piss off thor even more where
he's like my grandfather
you killed my papa
you killed my dick now speaking of
speaking of uh more and gore and thor
we also see we see gore
thrust his
sword into that land right like we also
see a later shot of like what looks like
a moon or a tiny planet kind of like
vibrating or exploding or something like
that shacks raining down
longitudinally
eric in the breakdown speculated that
could be
gore killing a celestial before they've
hatched
out of their weird celestial egg in the
core of a planet like do we think that's
possible i mean i like i think it's a
cool idea and i really like it though
that planet makes him a villain right
yeah if he kills an infant like i i
guess
well they were trying to kill
or they were trying to kill thanos
thanos thanos thanos
and no matter what in the chat y'all
gonna make fun of the way i pronounce it
you think it's pronounced i think it's
pronounced tejanos
i think
i'll be asking that question at
celebration too what's up with his
famous
what's up with this thing show me
thrawn's thing
yeah i think i think like these and and
more like the backstory the motivation
some of the details of gore there's like
a great
more so than maybe a lot of marvel
villains there's a great way they can
tie him into so many existing
characters properties mythologies all
kinds of stuff i think it's gonna be
epic the way they do this um and and
we'll be excitedly enthusiastically
talking about gore probably for the next
week or so uh when we're not talking
about obi-wan and ms marvel and some of
the other properties um but now we want
to thank some of the folks that help us
bring this show to you specifically this
week we're uh celebrating our friends at
athletic greens tommy's holding his
athletic green shaker cup there uh
tommy's a big fan of their ag-1 product
that he mentioned earlier he's taken
with him they got these nice little
travel package you can take with you to
star wars celebration
um
tommy you've you've been drinking that
every day how are you feeling i mean i i
gotta say i'm a chronic napper i'm a man
who loves to nap
i have not felt compelled to nap this
week since i've been taking the athletic
greens now i don't know if it's because
we've had so much exciting news but i i
got to be honest with you i think you
know i definitely noticed an increase in
energy and i also notice uh an increase
in sharpness i feel a little sharper you
feel you know you've seemed sharper we
hung out in person a little bit last
night and you were sharp as a tech tommy
tommy's been killing it on the work sl
also the other day i i was outside and
this woman screamed oh my god there's a
bearded baby look how smooth that
bearded baby's skin is but he's all
alone where are his parents someone
thought because my skin looks so good
that i was a baby and they came up and
they swaddled me in one of they put they
took a tarp down from uh from a car wash
they swaddled me in the tarp and then
like seven people lifted me up and
rocked me to sleep they thought you were
a six foot tall bearded baby yeah they
said look at that giant bearded baby
and then i can't help it you know me i'm
a consummate showman so i started crying
like a baby then i got on my back and
put my legs and hands up in the air and
yeah i really sold it for him anyway
thank you
so you're gonna sell on it uh yeah
tommy's feeling so good because he's
getting those 75 high quality vitamins
minerals probiotics and all that other
great stuff uh to start his day off
right with athletic greens you know the
backstory of athletic greens is is kind
of interesting the the founder was this
guy who was kind of diagnosed with all
these gut issues and and he started you
know he had to develop this like
treatment plan of like all these
different um complicated like
supplements and all this kind of stuff
and it was a lot of different pills and
things and it was expensive and so he
developed athletic greens as like this
nice simple optimal nutrition plan and
now we all get to benefit from that as
well and right now it's time to reclaim
your health and arm your immune system
with convenient daily nutrition just one
scoop and a cup of water every day
you'll be feeling as good as baby tommy
uh that's it no need for a million pills
and supplements uh to look out for your
health to make it easy athletic greens
is going to give you a free one-year
supply of immune boosting vitamin d and
five free travel packs you can take with
you to star wars celebration or any
other event uh with your first no no
okay simple sorry so
get out of here uh all you have to do is
visit athletic greens.com
break room slash break room again that's
athleticgreens.com
break room the link's probably in this
description of this video as well you
can just click it there take ownership
over your health and pick up the
ultimate daily nutritional insurance and
then i also just want to plug real quick
um our our merch partners over at
newrockstarsmerch.com
in the next few days they're going to be
dropping a brand new latest obsession
shirt for obi-wan it's a very cool
shirt they've got a whole line planned
for obi-wan these are the limited
edition shirts when you buy it you can
unlock a feature where you get to leave
a message that um will play during
wikileaks that tommy and eric vos host
they'll even read out some of those if
you want to ask a question leave a shout
out whatever it might be uh you can get
that you can unlock that feature by
buying one of those latest obsession
obi-wan shirts so keep an eye out if
you're a subscriber to the uh epic hero
merch newsletter you'll get notified the
second they go live cool all right now
tommy i normally transition to you doing
mandatory fun
too bad because
this girl is hosting mandatory fun play
my damn graphic john oh no
jessica you don't know what you're doing
if you don't
do stuff together you is for you and me
and is for anywhere at any time at all
and play my graphic for mandatory fun
one more time that's twice baby
it's for fire that burns down the whole
town u is for uranium bomb
and is for
[Applause]
it's mandatory fun you guys this is the
mandatory fun hosted by jessica clements
this time because you know why
yesterday's mandatory fun i won not
tommy not brandon and not zach and
certainly not john it was me
i stand for gore the god butcher and i
won and my winnings is to host today's
mandatory fun and for today's mandatory
fun
we are all still hyped for thor love and
thunder as brandon said we're never not
gonna be hyped for that that trailer
just dropped we're still excited about
it but
who is our true leader and who is our
true captain is it star-lord or is it
thor
um and now that we're gonna see the
guardians a little bit in thor love and
thunder i think we need to finally
address some things that we have
questions about
so
we're gonna figure out who our real
captain is i'm gonna give you guys five
quotes
five quotes you have to guess if this is
a thor quote
or a star-lord quote
in the chat
feel free to give out your answers of
what you think it is in the chat make
sure you can do like a star for
star-lord a lightning bolt for thor you
can just yell it if you want you can be
like jessica you're wrong but i know i'm
not
so are y'all ready are you guys ready
we're gonna see who really knows also
marvel through these quotes are we
buzzing in are you going one by one no
we're gonna i'm gonna read the quote and
then i'll do brandon zack tommy and you
guys tell me who you think it is you can
even give me a little explanation but
you don't have to you can just give me
whatever you want and then i'll say who
the right one is ready okay okay for our
first quote
for the first time in my life i have no
idea what i'm supposed to do
i'll repeat for the first time in my
life i have no idea what i'm supposed to
do who said this was this thor or was
this star-lord brandon i'm going to you
first i'm going to say thor in the first
thor film directed by kenneth
no that's too much
that gets you no yeah i was like that
gets you no extra points but if you want
to say it go ahead
zach i i'm also leaning thor he's a
person who's kind of like dramatically
changes his destiny that yeah so i'm
gonna say thor
okay and i get you extra points if you
get it right
tommy
uh
tommy already won this one
this one is of course said by star-lord
in guardians of the galaxy
part du
parde
though i want to give you all points
the correct answer is thor
so brandon and zach that's one point
one point brandon and zach
next quote are we ready are we ready yes
we've already established that you are
destroying that you destroying this ship
i'm on is not saving me who says this i
will repeat we've already established
that you destroying the ship i'm on is
not what is not saving me
brandon
i'm gonna i'm gonna say
it's not telling me star-lord says that
one
i'm gonna say star wars
zach zach a little bit of me thinks this
might be a trick question and this might
be from ragnarok where
thor definitely did a lot of spaceship
driving and ryden but i'm going to say
i'm also going to go star-lord
all right all right
zach will get extra points if this is
correct
tommy
uh
[Music]
oh no there's a jam
i'm never gonna get tired of this damn
fluke uh the answer is thor as said to
valkyrie in the movie thor ragnarok oh
[Music]
all of you guys had great answers
but the answer is star-lord
it is star-lord
brandon and zach are at two points each
tommy's had zero but tommy i'd give you
six we'll split it up third one
sometimes the thing you're searching for
your whole life is right by your side
all along
sometimes the thing you're searching for
your whole life has been right by your
side all along who said it
brandon star lord he says it to gamora
yep oh zak you're a green star-lord yes
okay and tommy
you're simply wrong
said by uh vincent d'onofrio's thor in
adventures in babysitting oh
if you guys want me to give your point
to tommy i can but some of you are also
wrong it is star-lord
it's star-lord
fourth one fourth one
who's this purple weirdo
who's this purple weirdo purple weirdo
yeah
okay
i'll go first here i feel brad well i
feel bad that brain always has to go
first because then i've just i see it
seems like i'm copying his answers
a tough one because i feel like that's
the kind of line both of these
characters would deliver
but i'm i'm going to say star-lord
okay weirdo feeling feels like a
star-lord word
i'd like to go last
i'm going to say
thor maybe it's that a little knife
little knife guy what's his name after
his name oh yeah not meek but
yeah yeah i think he's meek beep
uh
you're both wrong
the answer
is
uh
i know this the answer is rocket
the answer is rocket
okay no matter what i said that at the
top of the show that it is the horror
horror star wars it's an ab answer and
you can't pick and see start start then
i think it's
the storylord stored
okay so both how do they
both the correct answer is thor that's
what i said the answer is thor nope you
did it only brandon got that last one
are you mocking me
are you mocking me
i feel like one of them says it to the
other one i think de niro says this in
goodfellas right
i'm tired of you tommy tommy i've had it
up to here with the pesci
peshi lord
i amuse you
i'm gonna go are you mocking me
i think oh go ahead brandon
i'll say i think thor says it to
star-lord
yeah i'm gonna say that as well sure
you're both simply wrong uh it's
star-lord uh as said to john c reilly's
character in guardians of the galaxy one
you're all wrong
it was both of them
they both say are you mocking me when
they
you have to say both and the winner is
tech technically the winner is brandon
so what oh okay that's fine that's right
thanks for letting me
host mandatory fun jessica you did an
amazing job and because you did such an
amazing job i now place the mandatory
fun crown on you for the remainder of
the week you are in control of mandatory
fun for two more days but then monday
tom squad's back and we're you guys on
monday we're on vacation i think monday
we're on vacation monday i'll be
celebrating memorial day or
acknowledging or observing memorial day
i will play as loudly as tommy and i
will flirt with everyone in the
contestants like tommy and i will have
also an alternate personality that comes
out uh her name is dianne simmons and
she
she works for caa oh yeah
with anybody who's talking about she's
like
a girlfriend watching and you passed my
info too no flirting here what a
backstory um now
first off
uh tommy jessica myself
producer john philip molina all got to
go last night to the imax screening an
early screening of top gun maverick
um i almost screwed up the tickets but
we got in we didn't miss any of the
footage you almost screwed up the
tickets yes we missed so funny it is so
funny we missed the first half of uh the
nicole kidman uh well we walked in right
and she said somehow heartbreak feels
good in this place yes
for the folks at home this is a classic
exact move i feel like almost screwing
up the tickets but still getting it
coming through in the end but coming
through in the end and we have a lot of
thoughts on the screening big shout out
to imax i will say we'll talk a little
bit about our thoughts no spoilers um
you've got to see this movie and imax
i'm not just saying this
because they they let us see it for free
and they hooked us up shout out to uh
gabriella and zoe who who are able to
hook that up with with imax um this is
just the
movie that's made for imax i mean it's
incredible uh but it is so yeah i did i
wasn't there so i will be the proxy for
the audience all you folks at home who
also have not got to see the film yet i
i'm very sad not to be there my first
big question is like and i've seen this
in a lot of the trailer footage i'm i'm
sure it's real like this is some we're
seeing some real
planes doing some real stuff it doesn't
feel like a bunch of cgi that's what tom
cruise said before the movie started
yeah he was he there
was he there he came out
they showed a clip of him okay okay okay
yeah
they allowed 200 question quiz during
the movie to do a personality test it
was pretty cool interesting
that's very give each other nicknames
like they do for the floor
what would be your call sign i know i i
wanted cyclone because i i can shake my
body and then there's someone in the
movie named cyclone so yeah john hamm
john hammer cyclone so i would take that
name i would be chameleon
that'd be my name because i'd be on the
radio doing different voices when i was
flying the plane i'd be like yeah i'm
going to file a mitchell sheen we're
going to find them
that's chameleon that's too long of a
name to use oh no
camellia we need you we're going down oh
i'm so sorry i can't visa right now i'm
an old grandma
wow and then you've already exploded by
the time you get through all those stuff
yeah well that way the the enemies don't
understand there are some great new call
signs of course we get iceman and
maverick both can mention as somebody
already said cyclone hangman coyote
um there's some really good ones payback
yes payback is a fun one now do you guys
do you guys think uh the news this week
was that like this movie's projected to
take in uh 180 million dollars in its
global opening this weekend i think it's
opening everywhere this weekend
and they've been sitting on this movie
for like two years i think people are
really excited to see it
if it makes a 180 million global opening
this would be the biggest
global opening for a tom cruise movie
ever which i thought was really easy
yeah is it impossible dude
no i mean maybe i mean certainly
grossing overall more but in the first
week this will be the first one
and i think they've been helped with one
like you said anticipation two
a lot of people have seen this movie in
advance they've screened it for critics
you know usually when something like
this a big sequel that they what do they
call legacy sequels where there's a huge
gap between the first and second film a
lot of times they don't screen it for
for for for a lot of uh reviewers until
the very last minute because they're
worried that it's gonna get panned and
then people will just skip it this one
has been seen by almost everyone that
would review the movie and it's
overwhelmingly positive yes right like
that
such a good i
can't i'm seeing it again like it is
it's so fun it's so fun i like this one
more than the first one for me
personally i thought it was very fun and
so close to pride month it is
outstanding and i did want to i did want
to mention my call name would be back
shots
it kind of sounds like bechtel too it
has a
don't worry his plane just flew into the
side of a mountain
we don't have to worry about him anymore
mine's gonna be donkey punched okay
all right
this is serious
back shot doggy punch get in my office
all right you guys you know what mine
might be and if this is mine would be
hollandaise
uh both because i'm uh
creamy and white and
and delicious okay so you're not gonna
tell zach to stop
does that stuff no zamasu
and he's just speaking his truth right
now
oh he's gonna he's gonna nickname
himself hollandaise and everyone's gonna
call him zach
you can't make your own nickname it gets
forced upon you by unwillingly uh i i
want to say going back to like this
making a ton of money i agree you know
tom cruise has the kind of star power he
forced the studio not to drop this on a
stream that's right paramount wanted to
put this on paramount plus just like you
know hbo max did with so many of the big
films over the last like year and a half
he refused to let them do that he
insisted on it had to be a big
theatrical opening that's why i got
delayed so long but like i will say
it's a pretty great theatrical
experience now this was biased this was
an early screening i still i'm wearing
my pen that we got last night um but the
number of applause breaks during this
film not just like at the end or after
like a big battle or something like that
like
random character shows up applause
random line gets dropped applause like
the audience was jacked for this from
like the gray-haired old dudes that were
probably you know 20 when the original
came out to like the the 12 year olds
coming to see it with their parents
right like this felt like a four
quadrant movie in that classic style
it's very much like a pg-13
action feel good popcorn with great
80s and 90s action lines you know like
lines that said in real life you'd be
like that person is insane but somehow
you know
you know lines like that feel good in a
place like this it just works it just
works now uh
uh do you think you need to re-watch the
og no come on are you coming fresh can
you come in i think you do i think you
do i did i also haven't watched like i
realized it's been so long since i've
watched top gun but there were like if
you've never seen the original top gun
there will be too many times in this
movie you'll be like who is this who is
this
i think that you will not be worse for
the wear if you watch the original one
because you get to watch original top
gun and two because it will make a lot
of the connections even more
strong for you when you watch it but as
zach said they do spoon feed you a
pretty much any really key
connections you'd need to make are like
here is a literal
flashback of this scene of these two
people and this is why they feel this
way about each other so
it's a short movie it's also on netflix
the first one yeah um to watch and
there's a part in the first one i
specifically there's clearly a very
dramatic scene i'm not trying to spoil a
movie that came out like 40 years ago
there's a very dramatic scene that
didn't
grab me emotionally as much as it did in
this movie the second one and the second
one i felt deep about it but in the
first one i was like you guys didn't
make i didn't i wasn't strong
i wasn't close enough to i guess this
plot as i was in this movie the second
one
that's a good way of putting it jessica
and and again i can't i can't say enough
the imax of it all so go to a theater
with great sound like imax theaters
often have because this is like when
these jets are taking off
you feel like you're on the deck of
these aircraft carriers like the gut the
gut rumble is insane definitely not for
the faint of heart though no that that
shot of a jet engine going it vibrated
through my chest i was next to john the
entire time
grabbing him and yeah you guys remember
right
i'm always like grabbing his arm and
shaking him at scenes and being like
whispering
we also moved our seats we stole
different others
right john we're bad people and i got to
say one of the craziest cameos from r2d2
that we've seen in any film so far i was
going to say is is the rumor true that
uh maverick winds up fighting all the
different mavericks from across the top
gun first how did you know
i
[Music]
[Laughter]
and if this is too spoilery tell me it's
too spoiler and you refuse the answer
but like
do they have someone to fight in this
movie i mean yes and they they handle it
it's not an ai i handle it like an ai
there's an enemy country that is
literally never named
we never see a flag we never see uh they
never name a city or a country or a
region um it appears to have like an
alpine vibe there's some evergreen trees
and some snow on the ground i thought it
was clearly canada
is it zakovia is it zakovic come on oh
it's
confirmed uh and we'll we'll maybe talk
a little bit more about
top gun uh maverick in in the coming
weeks i don't know that we're going to
cover a lot on new rockstars we'll see
if if you really want us to do a
breakdown of that throw that in the chat
let us know otherwise we're gonna um
hit a few super chats here really quick
thank you for everybody that was
chatting along with us in the show and
throwing in super chats we appreciate
you uh orton chopin saying need to hear
from the big head gang can i get a shout
out big head gang
uh big head gang baby gang tommy's got
his hat on right now shout out to you
orton chopin uh just me saying do you
guys think thor is going to visit
omnipotent city
i'm not familiar with that i assume
that's a reference to the comics yeah
it's like something in the comics it's
like uh i think it's basically like the
court or something
i think it's like part of the celestial
or cosmic court i think it's like one of
those weird interdimensional places
where
big big cosmic stuff happens yeah i
guess you'll just have to watch for
yourself you freaking nerd i'm there
uh real quick rupert rupert jameson
might have my favorite check on what
i've seen in a long time
famous because they
because they ate us
diana's
come on the show that is that good lord
you're hired famous because
oh
match match 143 did say tommy's call
sign should be potty mouth
oh
good one i like that i do like back shot
but what about big head
you get back tall i don't care
it's facial you guys
i like potty mouth and i'm sorry mouth
is good it's a little cleaner what's
this guy's name his call sign is cream
pie get him out of here
okay he plays the flute he plays the
flute really quick and then scrolls oh
this wasn't a flute this is thanos's
dick i'm sorry about it okay
wow it is wednesday the swear jar never
got closed uh he's trying to get it all
in before he's gone for the rest of the
year yeah i'm gonna miss you guys come
on again we thank everybody for
channeling with us and for watching this
episode for watching all of our break
room episodes we appreciate you you make
this even more fun to do we'll be back
tomorrow and friday same time i will be
back in the studio tomorrow so if you
haven't loved this remote look we
haven't loved it as much either
i need to get back in the office or my
cat will keep terrorizing me you guys do
not understand yes i mean this show's
always a blast to do but it's a whole
different vibe and it's a different fun
energy in the studio so we'll be back
there starting tomorrow tommy will be uh
reporting back from star wars
celebration and we'll be having fun the
rest of the week so uh thank you again
everybody have a great rest of your day
[Music]
you